les grands son vice président de
l'assemblée nationale et député de parry
de la république en marche
l'invité d'auditions publiques bonsoir
soirée beaucoup merci d'être avec nous à
l'heure où paris brûle lit-on encore
dans la presse ce matin en vue des
municipales de l'an prochain merci donc
d'avoir répondu à notre invitation alors
que vous défendez ne vous n'êtes pas le
seul à votre candidature face à benjamin
griveaux qui serait déjà dit ont adoubé
avant même la réunion de la commission
d'investiture avec moi pour vous
interroger une rançon ce soir en brosse
une au luc une au vu de la sp et qui est
la spécialiste afp des questions
parisienne et puis vincent roux du
figaro et du figaro il arrive d'ailleurs
les internautes du figaro peuvent réagir
durant cette émission sur le chat vous
réagissez vous posez vos questions je me
ferais votre interprète tout à l'heure
dans la deuxième séquence de l'émission
marie noëlle lienemann sénatrice de
paris appartenant maintenant ou
communistes
et puis marie christine dalloz députée
les républicains du jura viendront vous
interpellez enfin pour lcp public sénat
brigitte boucher oriane machine mancini
bien sûr viendront comme chaque semaine
clore leur que nous allons passer
ensemble wheeler et j'ai noté que
c'était plus que la durée que va vous
accorder le 9 juillet la commission
d'investiture et puisque vous allez
pouvoir présenter votre projet pour
paris pour battre anne hidalgo avec un
oral de 45 minutes seulement en outre
nous avons une heure à passer en sens
d'être du coup est-il plus important de
réussir celui là a peut-être d'abord
c'est important d'autant que
c'est peut-être les jeux sont déjà faits
en fait je suis désolé de gaulle dit
vous avez vu aujourd'hui la commission
d'investiture qui vous a répondu dans
circulez il n'ya rien à négocier
donc les jeux sont faits pour paris
écoutez je ne crois pas que les jeux
soient faits vous avez aujourd'hui six
candidatures six candidatures de qualité
six candidatures qui ne proposent pas
les mêmes choses et qu'ils n'ont pas le
même profil nous avons tous les six des
profils différents des tempéraments et
des caractères différents nous avons des
identités politiques différentes j'ai
moi même travaillé pendant près de dix
ans aux côtés de jacques chirac
nous avons un rapport à la ville qui est
différent j'y suis né à paris c'est ma
ville c'est ma vie aussi
et je crois que nous avons justement à
défendre ses propositions à défendre ses
visions pour la ville c'est vision que
nous avons à proposer aux parisiens donc
ne comptez pas sur moi ne sont pas faits
évidemment que non les jeux ne sont pas
faits il n'y a pas de hasard aucune
assurance
il n'y a pas de croiser votre offensive
il n'y a pas de candidature naturelle
il n'y a pas de candidature imposé il y
à une procédure qui sera à la fin jugés
par une commission nationale
d'investitures bien sûr mais ne comptez
pas sur moi pour participer à
l'emballement de la journée qui est un
emballement qui n'a pas lieu d'être si
personne n'a parlé de primaires
j'entends justement
dans la tribune que vous avez signé hier
cosigné hier vous appelez à une
concertation ouverte aux citoyens
concrètement ça veut dire quoi
concrètement ça veut dire que à partir
du moment où vous avez une compétition
entre six candidats qui ne sont pas
adversaires mais qu'ils sont concurrents
parce qu'ils n'ont pas les mêmes visions
les mêmes projets ou les mêmes solutions
il faut laisser le temps à ces
différentes personnalités d'aller à la
rencontre des marcheurs des citoyens des
parisiens d'organiser des débats des
débats sur des plateaux télé bien sûr
mais les débats entre nous des débats
devant devant les marcheurs de quoi
parce que je crois qu'il ne faut pas
rentrer justement dans la lazio et
prenez vous nous dites que vous n'êtes
pas d'accord je n'ai pas le même projet
on n'est pas la même vision de par
crédit suisse et mara doxa de le voir
puisque vous vous allez changer dida à
l'investiture la république en marche et
vous êtes vous nous dites on est on a
tous des projets différents à quoi nous
aspirons c'est de pouvoir ouvrir un
débat démocratique entre eux la décision
d'une commission qui se prendrait
rapidement peut-être même précipitamment
entre les murs d'un parti politique le
10 juillet l'hypothèse d'une primaire
qui serait à l'évidence une mauvaise
solution parce qu'elle pourrait diviser
et bien il y a une voix cette voie
médiane c'est une voix assez simple dans
le débat démocratique en france c'est
celle justement de l' échange c'est
celle de la participation citoyenne
allons voir les citoyens allons voir
nous sortons d'une phase le projet paris
et moi c'est déjà un projet qui est
fondée sur la concertation de vos
militants et des parisiens donc cette
concertation citoyenne que vous appelez
qu'est ce que c'est concrètes pour être
précis paris moi c'est la phase de
diagnostic on l'a toujours dit les
choses ont été très claires dans le
mouvement auquel j'appartiens faisons
d'abord un diagnostic partagé
en suivant l'exemple de ce qui s'est
passé à l'occasion de la grande marche
en 2016 2010
sur la base de cette consultation et de
ce diagnostic partagé avec les parisiens
nous allons travailler à un projet le
projet du parti politique auquel
j'appartiens il y à des ateliers qui
sont menées par le mouvement politique
de la république en marche avec des
groupes de travail qui font un travail
de grande qualité et nous avons dit
ensuite qu'une fois le projet présenté
nous travaillerions à l'incarnation il
se trouve que j'ai le sentiment que nous
parlons de l'incarnation avant même de
parler du projet reste on sait comment
ils en sont en débat en des bacs comores
dans quel cadre et après on fait quoi de
ces débats alors ces débats c'est au
mouvement de l'organiser aujourd'hui
vous avez une décision qui a été prise
la commission nationale d'investitures
nous a dit qu'elle souhaitait que nous
venions vous l'avez rappelé cherchait
rien en version le 9 juillet nous
sortons à peine de l'épisode des
européennes
nous entamons le chapitre des
municipales personne n'a parlé des
européennes jusqu'à présent même ceux
qui sont partis pardon des municipales
même ceux qui sont partis tôt n'ont pas
parlé des municipales puisqu'il parlait
des européennes
moi même j'ai décidé de prendre le temps
de respecter les échéances de me
consacrer pleinement à l'élection
européenne et j'ai décidé d'annoncer ma
candidature
le 3 juin dernier pourquoi ai-je
annoncer ma candidature j'ai beaucoup
réfléchi
oui j'ai beaucoup consulté j'ai beaucoup
écouté aussi ce qui était dit parce
qu'ils avaient décidé de partir plus tôt
je considère qu'aujourd'hui
ma vision pour paris repose sur des
enjeux que j'ai déterminé et qu'ils
n'ont pas été abordés encore par les
autres votre nom le temps du débat ayant
le temps de les changes et cet échange
là il se fait dans des réunions avec un
travail de l'aveyron minutes évidemment
ça ne saurait suffire mais bien sûr
c'était passé 45 minutes
ce n'est pas une question d'être
ridicule quand il s'agit j'ai eu des
débuts de considérer que ma conviction
c'est qu'on ne décide pas d'un projet
pour paris d'un cap pour parer d'une
stratégie et d'une méthode de
rassemblement parce que nous y viendrons
je crois que paris ne se gagnera pas par
un parti politique bien je ne crois pas
que c'est en faisant un entretien de 45
minutes avec une décision le lendemain
que nous y parviendrons à vous je pense
est la leur
chavez coprésident de la commission
d'investiture qui a assuré ce matin dans
le parisien
ben ils vous s'adresse à vous notamment
mais vous pourrez parfaitement montré
lors de votre grand oral donc tous les
éléments qui démontrent le soutien de
l'opinion vous pouvez non mais ça vous
rassure il obtient des éléments à
apporter sur le soutien les parisiens
aujourd'hui d'ailleurs n'ont que faire
de ces procédures de désignation de ses
procédures de partis ou c'est moi je
suis je me suis lancé dans cette
bataille il y a quinze jours depuis
quinze jours on parle du ralliement des
maires d'arrondissement et l'air on
parle de mécanique partisane on parle d'
allianz
on parle de procédure de désignation et
on ne parle jamais de ce qui concerne
les parisiens à savoir les solutions que
nous avons à leur apporter mon obsession
dans cette candidature
ce sera de parler au parisien pardon de
vous dire michel grossiord et que le 9
juillet dans 15 jours nous n'aurons pas
eu le temps d'aller voir les parties
sont des parents peep et le 9 juillet
les dés sont les dés ne seront pas
nécessairement pipés je considère et je
les dis que nous devons prendre le temps
de ce débat entre la décision précipitée
et la primaire il y a le temps du débat
démocratique décidons à la rentrée à la
rente à la rentrée et de ce qui sera le
meilleur profil
la meilleure stratégie la meilleure
méthode est d'ailleurs arrivé l'horizon
c'est la ceni qui décidera mais vous
savez dans ce que je dis aujourd'hui je
crois que c'est l'intérêt de tous c'est
l'intérêt d'abord du candidat qui sera
choisi pourquoi parce qu'il pourra une
fois qu'il lancera sa campagne se
reposait sur un débat un dialogue est
évidemment rassemblement avec les autres
candidats c'est là qu'on réussisse
terminée - terminer là dessus c'est un
ses intérêts aussi de la ceni elle même
puisque la commission d'investiture
pourra motiver sa décision sur la base
de dynamiques qui auront été créés sur
des propositions sur des profils sur des
caractères et puis c'est l'intérêt avant
tout je vais dire des parisiens parce
que les parisiens je voulais dit ils
n'ont rien à faire des procédures
partisane en revanche les solutions que
nous avons à leur apporter
ça les regarde et aujourd'hui je pense
que nous devons porter ses convictions
la ses solutions ses visions ce projet
pour paris devant les parisiens et la
commission nationale d'investitures
désignera à la rentrée sans difficulté
et en rassemblant toutes les énergies et
toutes les dynamiques
qui aura été créé sur la base d'une
procédure enrichi entendu sur la
primaire emmanuel macron ce soir il
semblerait selon nos confrères qu'il
n'écarte pas l'organisation d'une
primaire à paris écoutez moi je n'ai pas
de position de là dessus ce sont des
propos rapportés jeudi connaissaient
j'en ai mal à une malformation est ce
que je peux vous dire aujourd'hui c'est
que je suis en campagne je suis en
campagne pour apporter des solutions à
des problématiques réelles dans la vie
des parisiens et que je crois que nous
ne pouvons pas nous construire avec des
méthodes que nous avons nous mêmes
dénoncé il y a deux ans je crois que la
volonté est là
la dynamique qui a porté le président de
la république au pouvoir sont des
dynamiques qui justement reposer sur une
autre façon de faire la politique sur
delà de l'intelligence collective sur du
débat nous sommes nous-mêmes sortie
d'une période très compliquée il y a
quelques semaines en créant et en
lançant ce grand débat national le débat
c'est aussi ce qui permet on a compris
en gros le débat il faut des débats et
finalement après la cni qui tranche
c'est votre c'est votre position en
septembre le débat bon à paris et même à
l'intérieur de votre parti c'est très
polarisée pour vous c'est quoi le plus
important c'est tout sauf griveaux tout
sauf hidalgo se sera jamais où ça on ne
se construit jamais contre qui que ce
soit nos amis derrière noah monde est
réellement la capa à nos amis des
républicains ont essayé de faire du tout
sauf macron un programme électoral pour
les élections européennes ça n'a pas
fonctionné et on voit dans quel état sa
des amis je ne ferai jamais eu de la
politique contre quelqu'un je porte un
projet pour les localiser le projet que
je porte pour les parisiens j'aspire à
pouvoir leur expliquer leur proposer à
créer une dynamique de rassemblement
beaucoup plus large que la seule
république en marche et je crois que
c'est important que nous puissions en
échange alors c'est important vous êtes
en train de nous expliquer comment vous
estimez que vous soyez un meilleur
candidat que benjamin griveaux par
exemple c'est pas être ni rejet des
propositions aujourd'hui j'ai un
diagnostic sur paris sur la ville si ça
avait été défendu par d'autres ou si
j'avais été convaincu par d'autres je ne
serai pas aux environs est ce que vous
estimez vous
mais un meilleur candidat que benjamin
griveaux mais c'est pas être meilleure
l'aja malgré qu on est 6 nous avons si
les propositions des profils et des
projets ce contrat avec un samuel comme
un reflet de paris et moi avec le socle
commun qui est le diagnostic sur paris
et moi évidemment leurs membres
le sujet n'est certainement pas de faire
du tout seul regret vous le sujet de
choisir le meilleur candidat qui a la
meilleure méthode et qui pourra nous
donner les chances de gagner toute
attente à la question sur évident alors
j'y réponds si ce que parce que vous me
les poser le tout sauf hidalgo jeu j'ai
toujours dit qu'on ne construisait pas
une candidature sûre du tout sauf
hidalgo battre anne hidalgo n'est pas un
projet politique en soi il faut qu'on
puisse expliquer aux parisiens ce qu'on
est capable de leur apporter de
meilleures est ce qu'on peut faire de
plus sur des questions très concrètes de
la vie du quotidien du coût de la vie
anne hidalgo si elle avait des réponses
efficaces
les parisiens le sort et c'est ce qui
justifie aujourd'hui ma candidature mais
on ne se construit jamais contre
quelqu'un est en politique et en même
temps il faut rassembler les voix y
compris au soir du premier tour
dans la lettre que vous envoyer aux
marcheurs début juin pour leur annoncer
votre candidature vous écrivez paris ne
se gagnera pas à droite
paris ou pas à gauche mais en restant
nous-mêmes par ailleurs si on regarde la
projection des résultats aux élections
européennes et qu'on imagine ce que
pourrait donner les municipales il vous
faut un peu droite il vous faut un peu
de gauche également comment vous faites
quels sont vos alliances précisément le
diagnostic que je porte sur l'état de la
ville étape politique et on parlera je
l'espère des des solutions qu'on peut
apporter aux parisiens c'est qu' aucune
force politique aujourd'hui ne peut
prétendre gagner paris seul aucun parti
politique ne peut prétendre gagner paris
et que s'il est que si justement nous ne
voulons pas tomber dans les mécaniques
de la vieille politique à savoir nous
retrouver au soir du premier tour avec
des gens que nous aurions combattu
pendant des mois et des mois dans un
sous sol d'un café du 7e arrondissement
pour dire bon pour gagner il va
alors que je te donne tu l
arrondissement que je te confie t-elle
place sur telle liste et tu veux quoi
dans un exécutif parisien ce sont des
méthodes que je dénonce parce que c'est
toujours celle que j'ai récusée et c'est
celle que nous avons récuser ensemble en
2010 est ma conviction c'est que nous
faisons des années chiffres étaient en
amont au plus large possible
rassemblement progressive ça veut dire
quoi je tends la main à pierre-yves
bournazel je tends la main à gaspard a
grandi nous devons construire aussi avec
le moderne avec le modem que nous
n'écoutons pas assez dans la préparation
de ces élections municipales ce n'est
pas le sujet parce que la question des
errants sur la question des maires
d'arrondissement nous y répondre vous
invitez les formations politiques dites
à partisane c'est candidature ni de
droite ni de gauche à vous rejoindre
celle de pierre yves bournazel
je pense qu'aujourd'hui il ne s'agit pas
de faire de l'arithmétique politique
mais que nous devons discuter de
propositions des propositions des
dynamiques que nous devons partager
aujourd'hui je crois qu'il n'y a pas
assez de différences entre gaspard
grandeur et moi entre pierre-yves
bournazel et moi pour que nous lancions
des dynamiques concurrentes
je crois que nous devons créer un large
rassemblement à paris mais avant le
premier tour nous devons travailler sur
les questions du périphérique alors que
met en avant gasparin vers nous devons
travailler sur les questions de
démocratie locale sur lesquels travaille
car yves bournazel sur le sur le fond
des projets sur notre vision de la v6
aimant et c'est en assumant avant le
premier tour une dynamique de
rassemblement plus large que nous
élargirons la base de la république en
marche pour arriver légiste en tête au
premier tour et la météo s'est dit cette
élection munitions dans laquelle joue
tams et je les dis vous l'avez vous et
la gentillesse de rappeler on ne gagnera
il ya beaucoup de gens qui nous disent
on va gagner paris par la droite
d'autres gens qui me disent on va gagner
paris par la gauche
maintenant on nous dit et souvent les
mêmes un moment finalement on va gagner
paris en faisant un accord avec le parti
écologiste
aujourd'hui je considère que nous ne
gagnons pas rico restants nous manquer
la fidh
fidèles à notre promesse originelle
celle de faire de la politique
différemment et celle de porter un
projet celle de vastes les frontières
partisanes et celle de permettre et de
favoriser le puisque vous parlez de
frontières et de gasparian sert sa
proposition phare c'est de supprimer ce
qui fait de la frontière entre paris et
la banlieue selon lui c'est le
périphérique de proposition qui fait
frémir quand même pas mal d'habitants de
banlieue est ce que vous vous êtes
favorable à cette mesure radicale je
crois que nous avons en discute et je
pense que le périphérique
aujourd'hui ne satisfait personne je
pense que les questions de pollution de
sécurité routière de barrières qui
empêchent la ville justement de
raisonner avec ses partenaires
je crois que nous devons aménager le
périphérique je crois que nous devons
réfléchir à le couvrir le végétaliser je
ne dirais pas jusqu'à la suppression du
périphérique parce que je ne vois pas
aujourd'hui comment nous faisons mais je
trouve que c'est une proposition à 50
très intéressante la réduction de la
vitesse pour moi voilà un sujet sur
lequel il faut pas être dans le dogme
c'est pas 50 ou 70 je considère
qu'aujourd'hui nous avons les moyens
d'adapter la vitesse réguler surprise
adaptant parfois c'est 60 licences à
d'apparence et 50 pour vous avez tous
pris la voiture sur des autoroutes
aujourd'hui où la vitesse est régulée en
fonction du temps du climat actuel ses
comptables en 3g pour paris comment
peut-on résumer un triple diagnostic sur
l'état de la ville le premier diagnostic
c'est que paris qui est ma ville est une
ville où il ne fait plus bon vivre
vous avez un cadre de vie qui se
détériore et vous avez un coût de la vie
qui explose le cadre de vie parisien qui
exactement mais le cadre de vie qui se
détériore c'est ce dont on entend parler
au quotidien la propreté la sécurité la
pollution c'est l'anarchie dans les rues
l'anarchie dans les rues c'est pas que
les trottinettes cédé points de travaux
qui sont multiples c'est des
embouteillages la circulation nous
devons essayer d'apporter des réponses
concrètes dans le même temps vous avez
un coût de la vie qui explose à paris et
la municipalité doit faire de ce coût de
la vie une obsession pourquoi parce
qu'aujourd'hui des jeunes talents ne
peuvent pas venir s'installer à paris
c'est trop cher les familles qui veulent
y rester ou qui veulent s'agrandir ne
peuvent pas y rester sont obligés de
s'expatrier
d ailleurs m
avait une ville qui se paupérise vous
avez des classes moyennes pardon qui se
paupérise qui ce gentil fille vous avez
des classes moyennes et les classes ne
peuvent pas y rester moi je propose une
chose très concrètement les travaux en
matière très concrète pardon en matière
de coût de la vie
c'est de pouvoir intégrer le coût du
logement dans la tarification des
services publics municipaux ça veut dire
que si vous déduisez le coût du logement
de la tarification des crèches par
exemple la place de crèche
elle est moins chère la cantine et les
moins chères c'est du pouvoir d'achat
pour les familles et c'est forcément des
instruments musicaux qui vont permettre
aux familles de rester deuxième
diagnostic pardon parce que vous m'avez
demandé une attention secrètement la
mairie de paris se doit en disant
qu'elle n'est pas responsable de la
plupart des travaux qui ont en cours
aujourd'hui à paris et qui nuisent à la
vie quotidienne n'est pas raison qu'est
ce que vous faites leur métier justement
de développer les trois points sur
lesquels je pense que j'attends
le troisième point c'est le millefeuille
administratif à paris à paris
aujourd'hui vous avez un millefeuille
administratif des arrondissements une
mairie centrale
un préfet de région préfet de police une
région un grand paris il ya trop de
strates administratives
il ya aussi trop d'élus 1527 élue à
paris c'est évidemment trop la
répartition en arrondissement fait qu'il
y à la fois du conflit entre
arrondissements du conflit entre
arrondissements et mairie centrale
aussi c'est qu'il y à aussi une dilution
de responsabilité personne n'est jamais
responsable ce que vous me dites sur les
travaux annoncés pas nous et vous
préconisez qu'aux jeux de rang
conscience à se sortir de la logique
d'arrondissement de re confié de
pouvoirs à la mairie centrale pour
qu'elle puisse harmoniser les politiques
municipales du nord au sud de l'est à
l'ouest et de confier à des quartiers au
parisien la capacité à agir sur leur
quotidien
c'est au niveau du quartier que les
parisiens peuvent décider eux-mêmes
qu'il y ait un trou dans la chaussée ici
qu'il y a un lit complet engage à
l'appui la situation par de la chapelle
également mais bien sûr mais vous c'est
prenons l'exemple de la du quartier
barbès est pas exactement la chapelle le
quartier barbès ces trois
arrondissements le neuf le 17 18 qui
coexistent une mairie centrale qui est
au dessus et à préfet de police qui
intervient sur les questions de sécurité
publique comment mettre ensemble des
acteurs comment les mettre d'accord
alors même que les habitants ne sont
jamais consulté interroger les
associations du quartier barbès c'est la
même unité
de vie et c'est dans une unité de vie
qu'on trouve les réponses les plus
adaptées
le grand débat nous a dit qu'il fallait
plus de proximité et ramener une confier
le pouvoir aux citoyens
c'est évidemment ce que je propose à
l'échelle parisienne ont confié du
pouvoir aux citoyens
merci ambrée merci vincent nous allons
faire manuellement entre et les deux
dames qui nous attends tu les deux
parlementaires qui sont nos invités
cette semaine pour vous interpeller une
rançon avec nous donc marie noëlle
lienemann bonsoir vous êtes sénatrice de
paris vous appartenait maintenant au
groupe communistes républicains citoyens
écologistes et marie christine dalloz
députée et l'air du jura une question
d'un internaute du figaro d'abord eu
grand saut on vous demandait ce que
votre modèle c'est le pari de chirac
ah bah vous savez vous avez été proche
j'ai travaillé pendant dix ans avec
jacques chirac jolie brune change irak
de le voir j'ai pour lui fidélité et
affection je ne suis pas un ancien
chiraquien je suis chiraquien jacques
chirac premier jeu porte son héritage
j'ai pour modèle aussi à paris celui qui
a été un grand mère qui bertrand delanoë
et je pense que nous devons nous
inspirer de ceux qui ont porté des
projets pour la ville jacques chirac et
bertrand delanoë ont été de grandes de
grand mère pour la ville je suis
toujours chez les ricains et emma
chroniqueur même alors mais toujours
marie noëlle lienemann bonsoir c'est
christine dalloz bonsoir madame la
députée on a parlé beaucoup des
municipales à paris iv c'est un sujet
que vous réaborder mais peut-être sur le
plan national puisque cette fameuse
commission d'investiture est quand même
désigné ses premiers candidats
aujourd'hui pour la république en marche
avec certains qui qui viennent et qui
reste peut-être encore à droite
je constate quand même que pour un
nouveau parti qui n'avait pas de base
il ya deux ans aujourd'hui notamment sur
paris ça sera vrai aussi en le verra
dans d'autres villes il ya pléthore de
candidats c'est c'est une profusion de
candidats alors paris c'est la capitale
de la france certes mais la réalité
c'est que j'ai un peu le sentiment que
le nouveau monde puisqu'on nous a
suffisamment dit que c'était le nouveau
monde va peut-être faire pire que
l'ancien monde parce que six candidats
dans une même formation politique
l'ensemble d'une même formation
politique à la mairie de paris
d'ailleurs à aucun moment pour
et on a imaginé des primaires dans le
passé il ya eu une commission
d'investiture qui a qui a sélectionné
moi j'ai bien entendu que le président
éventuellement envisager président la
république envisager une primaire ça
serait vraiment une nouveauté et je vous
souhaite beaucoup de courage pour nous
sortir d'une primaire à paris voilà
c'est simplement mon commentaite chère
marie-christine dalloz je suis très
heureuse de vous retrouver sur ce sur ce
plateau je veux vous faire de rappel le
premier rappel c'est que il y a déjà eu
évidemment des primaires à paris en tout
cas à gauche puisque c'est ainsi que
bertrand delanoë en 2001 a su écarter
celui qui était jacques lang et puis
peut-être en 2001 je vous le rappelle
chère marie-christine dalloz vous qui
déplorait le fait qu'il y ait trop de
candidats vous aviez francs soit une
autre nation jacques toubon jean tiberi
philippe séguin est certainement bien
davantage encore et que ces gens là
d'ailleurs je vous le rappelle et il ne
faut pas forcément en tirer un
enseignement mais ne s'était pas
présenté à la commission d'investiture
puisqu'il considérait que l'été les dés
étaient pipés
essayons ensemble de nous inspirer de ce
qui s'est passé en 2001 et de considérer
que la voie de la désignation
après débat est toujours meilleure que
celle d'une ceni qui brutalise ray les
choses marie noëlle lienemann vous avez
regardé la liste des
sortant qui sont adoubés par la
république en marche vous y retrouver
certains nouveaux amis non je crois bon
indien en tout cas des socialistes en
tout cas un j'ai repéré qui est le maire
de pêcher sous bois pour ma part je
considère olivier klein je considère
qu'on vit dans une période de grande
ambiguïté enfin moi j'ai quitté le parti
socialiste est à nouveau parti
quand je républicaine sociale est
justement parce que cette ambiguïté me
paraissait néfastes et et que je pense
que ce débauchage une interpellation de
notre invité sur le prochain
personnellement j'ai téléchargé sur tous
les débouchés
qu'est ce que vous voulez c'est pas la
méthode que j'imagine et pour nos
attentes des français c'est à dire je
trouve que pour le coup ça fait quand
même assez politique politicienne alors
la sueur sur ce point je vais vous dire
quelque chose c'est qu'on va se
rejoindre moi je ne suis pas partisan de
la politique de débauchage je crois
qu'il n'y a pas de politique du
débauchage
je pense qu'il ya une formation
politique nouvelle qui a une
recomposition politique qui est réel
vous même je crois à madame lienemann
vous avez bougé par rapport à des
nantais des engagements antérieurs que
vous aviez c'est très bien il ya une
recomposition politique et que chacun
peut du coup faire cette démarche
personnelle et politique de dépasser ses
ancienne appartenance ou ses horizons
personnel professionnel politique
je crois que c'est tout à fait ça ce qui
ne serait pas certain en effet c'est de
considérer qu'on doit écarter tout le
monde est de considérer que moi je crois
en idéologie je crois dans le corpus
idéologique nous avons certainement avec
madame dalloz ou avec vous madame
lienemann beaucoup de points
d'achoppement mai mais faisons le sur le
fond travail on hésite on vous dira il
est des bâtons sur des projets de
société qui ne sont pas les mêmes et moi
je ne souhaite pas que la formation
politique à laquelle j'appartiens soit
une auberge espagnole où chacun
viendrait en fonction de ses propres
considérations de ses propres conditions
de travail travaillons nous à un corpus
idéologique réalité la réalité c'est que
c'est pas ça vous savez très bien que
manuel macron été élu en faisant en
donnant l'image de quelqu'un qui serait
de gauche et de droite que moi pour le
coup j'ai une fidélité de logique de
longue haleine
j'ai toujours pensé que ça n'existait
pas que c'était et de droite et de
droite et la réalité aujourd'hui et on
le voit lors des élections européennes
c'est que c'est clairement une politique
libérale qui parlent essentiellement un
électorat de droite donc ya pas de
recomposition pour une raison simple
c'est que l'idéologie qui est au jus
dominante dans le maquereau nisme est
une idéologie libérale de droite sont
libérables mais c'est une gabegie
libéral qui n'est en rien sociale
devrait donc voilà je le crois pas
vraiment ça ne vous étonnera qu'on a une
on a une divergence là dessus l'effort
que nous devons faire nous à la
république en mange c'est de se fixer un
corpus idéologique le en même temps
fallait en même temps c'est pas un coup
à droite un coup à gauche c'est pas de
la godille c'est précisément une
nouvelle philosophie politique qui nous
permet à la fois de penser la création
de richesses et en même temps la
distribution de richesse ça doit nous
permettre de penser à la fois la
question de la sécurité et l'ordre
public et la liberté de manifester c'est
le en même temps c'est une philosophie
et un corpus idéologique à part entière
et nouveau là où je ne vous rejoint pas
c'est quand vous dites que la politique
est une politique de droite
bon vous savez je je ne crois plus du
tout en cette dichotomie et bien vous
savez maintenant parce que moi et les
chèvres sur le rappelait tout à l'heure
j'ai travaillé pendant 10 ans auprès de
jacques chirac et je vous promets que
sur l'engagement politique de jacques
chirac auquel je crois et qui a façonné
ma vie mais on peut se trouver parfois
plus à gauche que certains qui ont été
je trouve scania dans leurs vies
antérieures et ses pas et s'est pas
complètement le vrai sujet aujourd'hui
ce n'est pas de savoir c'est droite ou
de gauche
le sujet de savoir ce à quoi on croit et
ce à quoi on croise à la fois que
twitter ils ont très bien repérer quand
on a 40% nuit
je veux bien qu'appelée cochet de droite
ils sont bien compris qu'on faisait une
politique pour rona on va regarder aussi
doucement parisien évidemment eu rançon
ou les amis
c'est pour qu'ils votent à droite qui me
feront se sont ralliés passive
aujourd'hui aujourd'hui la difficulté
qu'on a et on le voit bien
c'est flagrant à l'assemblée nationale
c'est certainement par et au sénat il
n'y a pas de groupe et les rues même
important de témoins d'un groupe
majoritaire pléthorique à l'assemblée
nationale on le voit bien dans les votes
dans les expressions dans les
discussions avec les collègues de la
république en marche quand il ya des
mesures de droite la gauche est en train
de taper du pied quand il ya des mesures
de gauche
l'ailé droite est en train de taper du
pied je vois pas comment vous en a pas
mal taper du pied mais bien sûr mais
c'est aussi mon rôle même si je sais
aussi je vous le rappelle j'ai aussi su
voter certaines dispositions
quand elle me convenait mais ce que je
trouve scandaleux c'est cette série dans
laquelle nous sommes rentrés juste
derrière les élections européennes
les élections européennes sont passées
hop on arrive on prépare les municipales
hélas le débauchage systématique mais de
tout le monde présidents de départements
président de région est l'une des
grandes villes on va même arrivé à
descendre dans les petites villes
la réalité c'est que vous êtes en train
d'essayer de reformer un mouvement
politique pour arriver à passer la
composent et la république en marche
partout sur le territoire
ce que vous n'avez pas de base et c'est
ça le problème moi je considère
aujourd'hui qu'il ya trois types d'élus
3dans là on approche des municipales il
ya des élus qui ont très peur
ceux qui ont eu très peur qui ont
regardé les résultats des élections
justes après les européennes et qui sont
dus ou là là ça va être difficile pour
ma mairie pour maman main ma région mon
département donc courage fuyons aveyron
allons chercher
écoutons l'appel des sirènes est alors
rejoint la république en marche grossir
les rangs de la république en marque
s'est fait à grands coups de
communication c'est extraordinaire il ya
ceux qui ont peur la deuxième catégorie
ceux qui ont peur mais qui sont plutôt
un peu caché en ce moment ils ont peur
mais pas suffisamment pour pouvoir
oui ils sont aux abonnés absents bon et
puis il ya ceux qui n'ont pas peur et
vous pouvez aller les chercher il y en a
qui ne qu'ils ne céderont pas au chant
des sirènes
mais je pense qu'on va vraiment
identifié dans les mois qui viennent
ce qui effectivement oran une base des
convictions et qui seront pas dans le
même temps que tu as fait raison daloz
je rebondis sur ce que vous vous disiez
minimum le sujet pas tant celui du
débauchage que des débauchés moi ce que
je veux dire c'est que ceux qui veulent
nous soutenir sont évidemment les
bienvenus il faut pas que ce soit des
déclarations d'intention il faut se
positionner par rapport à des actes que
pensent les je reviens à l'instant sur
paris pardonnez moi mais parce qu'on a
en effet beaucoup de maires
d'arrondissement élèves qui aujourd'hui
veulent par ce qu'ils ont vu les
résultats aux élections européennes
considéré que nous serions une bouée de
sauvetage ou une entreprise de recyclage
que pense-t-il réellement des questions
environnementales sont ils favorables la
piétonisation des voies sur berge
j'y suis pour ma part favorable sont ils
favorables à la réduction de la place de
la voiture j'y suis pour ma part
favorable sur les questions sociales en
matière de logement social questions que
vous connaissez parfaitement bien
quelle est leur position la mine est
très clair là dessus quelle est la
position sur l'accueil des réfugiés sur
la question sociétale nous allons
bientôt et je pense que ça pourrait nous
avons nous opposer madame dalloz
travailler à l'assemblée nationale sur
la pma pour toutes les femmes
est ce que ces élus des républicains qui
veulent nous rejoindre sont aujourd'hui
prêts à aller défendre ce projet faut
qu'il prenne un peu vous marquez un peu
à gauche son fils tu es allé défendre
les politiques
en tout cas le renouvellement politique
que nous plaît donc c'est là dessus la
politique ce ne sont pas que des paroles
ce sont des actes et il faut qu'il je
demande à ce qu'il y ait la part de ces
gens qui s'intéressent il va
nouvellement à nous je demande qu'ils
aient de la clarté facile et j'arrive en
gabas allez je rap mé c sur des îles à
une visibilité je n'en parlais pas enfin
il ya des sujets comme ça vous voulez
rassembler au plus large alors les
migrations la pma on sent bien que c'est
très les sujets sont quand même choisi
très parisien c'est clair mais la
réalité vous choses et pas beaucoup
entendu parler de la fiscalité à paris
de choses comme ça vous avez un grand
projet par rapport aux familles qui sont
exclus aujourd'hui aux familles moyennes
voire pauvres qui sont complètement
exclue du champ parisien moi j'ai un peu
le sentiment que vous allez faire une
politique très bobo excusez moi mais
c'est un peu ça paris paris est une
ville
la caricature personnel fait paris c'est
encore pour un peu de temps une ville de
diversité que paris n'est pas une ville
de bobo jeudi la place et quand on veut
parler que de supprimer les voitures
voies sur berge quand vous parlez pas
réalité des parisiens regarder ce
qu'elle est venue cette ville en
quelques années vous vous avez senti mes
difficultés les trottoirs il se trouve
que non seulement j'en suis l'élu sait
que j ai toujours vécu droit la
dégradation de l'état des villes je la
connais je profite de la position je me
suis s'était pas mirobolant quand on
avait plein de voitures avec tant de
fumée partout toutes les façades qui
était dégueulasse
si vous n'arrivez pas la réduction de la
place de la voiture c'est une politique
constante à paris de jacques chirac de
jean tiberi de bertrand delanoë et de
anne hidalgo
est ce un sujet de préoccupation des
parisiens oui paris est elle salle oui y
at il trop de pollution de l'air où ils
comment peut-on aller plus loin que ce
pied déjà fait par la municipalité
actuelle travail ausy j'ai pour ma part
un projet pour faire de paris une
capitale verte c'est un sujet essentiel
lorsque la qualité de l'air par exemple
non c'est une scène le verdissement
beaucoup d élus qui veulent soutenir la
république en marche
on était arquebouté contre ces projets
et donc j'attends avec impatience
comment la république en marche nous
expliquer que oui oui et l'écologique
moins de voitures etc
et comment elle va faire le lien avec
toute une série de gens dont on voit
bien qu'un certain nombre de contacts
sont déjà pris
mais madame humains pris position très
récemment pour dire que justement le pas
ce que j'appelais le hidalgo bashing le
fait de s'opposer systématiquement à
tous surtout n'avait aucun sens et que
c'était profondément antinomique avec la
promesse initiale qui a été la nôtre de
savoir voir les choses avec
bienveillance et savoir reconnaître
quand des projets doivent être
encouragés sur ces projets là vous me
trouverez toujours c'est ce qu'un accord
avec anne hidalgo la maire sortante les
camps visage mais de votre côté mais
vous imaginez les pommes répond michel
grossiord que ça fait 15 jours que je
suis candidat qu'on me parle d' alliance
avec aménagé comme un ami
l'alliance des solutions vous avez en
tête quand même soit de séduire à gauche
et puis soit éventuellement de passer
avec la maire sortant cette façon de
voir la politique à ce pas de manière
arithmétique n'est pas l'amiral mauzun
dit pas que c'est un enjeu cet art est
haussé à deux projets et de solutions à
apporter
quand la mère de paris à des actions que
je trouve bénéfique en matière de lutte
contre la pollution jeu libre à vous
marie noëlle lienemann vous voulez
aborder certains aspects de la politique
de réforme du gouvernement notamment
l'assurance chômage et puis les
retraites
non je voulais surtout posé la question
monsieur rançon sur l'état du pays en
matière économique et en particulier
industriels parce que paris est un lieu
où il ya beaucoup de services peu
d'industries
mais quand même nous sommes un grand
pays dans lequel il faut être attentif à
ce qu'on ne soit pas fragilisé au ce
week-end
il va y avoir une grande réunion avec
les salariés d'alstom à belfort
alstom est historiquement un des rares
grands fleurons industriels français qui
demeuraient il ya d'abord eu cette
erreur majeure d'avoir vendu la partie
énergétique d'alstom à general electric
c'est monsieur macron conseiller de
françois hollande qui a tout fait pour
ces lieux et s'est opposé monsieur
montebourg qui disait soyons
précautionneux ne le faisons pas si
besoin important pendant un moment part
du capital public cette grande
entreprise
puis il ya cet accord monsieur macro
ministre de l'économie ils signent un
accord dans lequel manifestement les
garanties n'ont pas été suffisantes pour
que les promesses soient tenues et où le
premier mans les 1000 emplois truc qui
paye on découvre aujourd'hui qui nous
avait annoncé que turbine gaz allait
avoir leur siège social en france et là
y ait pas de sanction donc on a signé un
accord sur lequel le pouvoir donc
derrière cette affaire-là
la question c'est que j'observe que dès
qu'il ya une crise industrielle
le ministre de l'économie elle présente
la république se refuse à toute
intervention du capital public fustige
temporaire et finit par acte et une
désindustrialisation du pays
mais c'est vrai aussi pour être beaucoup
plus parisien est ce que vous êtes
favorable la privatisation des dp alors
que dans beaucoup de pays du monde et
notamment les états unis
on sait à quel point ces aéroports sont
stratégiques
on sait à quel point c'est le premier
pro
estaires foncé d'île de france et on va
remplir les caisses des actionnaires
privés de future privatisation
éventuelle d'atp donc est ce que vous
allez appeler à signer pour le
référendum dany ps que vous êtes contre
la privatisation des deux avait déjà à
votre droite
quelqu'un qui a signé l'appel au
référendum d'initiative partagée puisque
dans ce dans ce nouveau monde
nous avons des élus des républicains qui
vont signer avec l'appel de la france
insoumise justement pour faire appel à
ce référendum est un oui c'est triste un
symbole alors moi je j'ai vu ça avec
avec beaucoup d'attention le sujet c'est
non à la privatisation de la dp dont la
voix la mer des libéraux ne sont pas
pour la favela pour la privatisation
puisque aux états unis il ya eu des
débats et la plupart du temps les états
ont gardé la maîtrise souveraine de
lozère je crois que toutes les
inquiétudes qui pouvait avoir lieu sur
ce sujet ont été levées je crois
vraiment en mes brevets pardonner mais
ensuite ce que nous pouvons en effet ne
pas partager ben manifestement faire
sachant que moi je suis très je joue
aujourd'hui à penser que je suis très
attaché à la politique industrielle je
pense que l'état a une capacité à
belfort qu'il faut le faire sans aucun
doute
moi je ne suis pas un ultralibéral qui
considérait que la main invisible a tout
réglé je crois en l'état et je crois que
l'aide à l'état et que la puissance
publique au niveau national comme au
niveau local a une capacité à agir sur
la question de la dépêche ce conte sur
la question de la dp je ne crois pas que
les intérêts stratégiques soit
aujourd'hui mis en cause par sécurité
immigration attendait vraiment ce matin
le patron du medef et une partie de
l'argumentaire de monsieur le maire qui
dit un aéroport c'est d'abord un support
commercial mais on plaisante
c'est d'ailleurs ce qu'il veut le faire
j'sais pas si vous étés à toulouse
c'était une débâcle générale mêlant vous
passer à travers tous les magasins pas
dans des voiries il faut passer au
milieu alors les gamins mon ami tu veux
m'acheter du truc vous vous débrouillez
pour essayer d'avoir l'avion ça n'est
plus fait pour les usagers c'est fait
pour du commercé
et la deuxième chose c'est que vous
pouvez pas nier que l'organisation de la
sécurité comme d'ailleurs le soutien à
notre compagnie nationale ne sont ces
mêmes préoccupations je vous garantis
que ces sujets là qui sont essentiels
par rapport aux questions de
souveraineté d'un état qui veut
intervenir sont des sujets qui ne seront
pas mis en rapport à l'arrière il va
s'agir rapporteurs vont maintenant j'ai
aussi au delà de la politique
industrielle de l'est sur la situation
économique du pays
et bien force est de constater pardon
vous décevoir l'une et l'autre et je ne
prends pas la brochure de la république
omar je prends le dernier rapport de l'
ocde que la situation économique du pays
est bonne que des envois salariés sont
créés l'action légale et sans arêtes
déficit public
je pense qu'il faut un moment donné de
sérieux les déficits publics ne sont pas
en train de se résorber
elle ne détenait pas en train de
diminuer a contrario quoi les pousser
leurs pions pour la même année
consécutive déficit seront en dessous
nuit oui sauf que c'est facile avec de
la croissance comme vous l'avez facile à
réaliser
c'est si facile alors que vous ne l'avez
jamais réussit très bien la
privatisation d'un ep si je me suis
opposée alors vous pouvez un petit peu
nous banaliser en disant vous êtes avec
la france a soumis ce traitement
nous ne sommes pas si la demande est
référé aujourd'hui on va justement parce
que j'étais nous alors à l'époque et
vous devriez vous en souvenir quittions
à l'origine de la privatisation des
autoroutes et qu'aujourd'hui on constate
que c'est une erreur profonde et vous
devriez vous en inspirer
parce qu'une privatisation d'un outil
aussi structurant que soit d'autoroutes
ou de l'aéroport c'est une ineptie
et de ce côté là où vous trouverez
toujours en phase de jeu ce que vous
trouvez en tout cas madame dalloz dans
les prochains débats budgétaires avec
nous quand il faudra nous appuyer sur la
baisse de la pression fiscale pour les
français ils voulaient la place de la
course
la baisse de l'impôt sur le revenu les
amish l'arrêter
la semaine dernière en matière fiscale
et on va dire économique par le premier
ministre je sais parce que je connais
votre engagement sur mon sujet je sais
pouvoir compter sur votre soutien merci
demande de soutenir l'économie nationale
et pas de la brader je constate
whirpool à alstom je constate qu'on a
fermé ford on nous dit qu'on va
restructurer et un rapport vient d'être
sorti que les restructurations casillas
qu'il a de quoi est ce qu'on va nous
sépare donc vous avez un point pourtant
c'est terminé merci merci beaucoup
dernière partie de l'émission maintenant
avec orianne mandelieu brigitte boucher
mesdames bonsoir je suis d'abord
philippe il est internaute il nous suit
sur le figaro live et vous demandent une
rançon est ce que vous êtes favorable à
un péage urbain à l'entrée de paris pour
réduire la place de la voiture je suis
tout à fait favorable à la seule
condition qu'il soit intelligemment mis
en place vous savez sur cette question
des mobilités
je crois qu'il faut sortir des dogmes ou
des postures il va falloir créer du
consensus parce qu'on voit bien que la
question des transports à paris est un
sujet majeur sur ce sujet là du
transport je souhaite une fois élu maire
de paris que une grande conférence des
mobilités puissent se réunir très
rapidement faisant intervenir tous les
acteurs les opérateurs publics et les
transporter les usagers les opérateurs
de trottinette des citoyens qui ressorte
parce qu'il faut qu'on mette on se met
d'accord ensemble sur des solutions
immédiates et sur une trajectoire
à 10 ans je crois dans l'intelligence
collective et je veux que cette
conférence des mobilités puisse nous
permettre d'aboutir à des situations
intelligente sur la question du péage
urbain
j'y suis favorable à la seule condition
que ce soit incitatif c'est à dire qu'on
puisse une fois qu'on a garé sa voiture
partir avec son ticket de péage et avoir
accès au transport gratuit dans la ville
c'est ça qu'il faut construire s'agit
pas de le décréter ou de le faire de
manière autoritaire ou arbitraires avant
une élection il faut qu'on le
construisent ensemble mais je crois
profondément qu'il faut sortir la place
de la voiture en tout cas réduire la
place de la voiture à paris et en tout
cas réduire de la voiture que puisqu'il
vient pénétré dans la ville où traverser
la ville vient de manière rapide et et
ça pose des questions évidemment à la
fois de sécurité et de pollution cogite
oui on a vu aux élections européennes
une grande sont que les électeurs de
droite s'étaient tournés vers vous plus
massivement qu'est la présidentielle ça
a provoqué le départ de laurent wauquiez
de la présidence et républicains et
valérie pécresse a quitté l'est
républicain quel regard vous vous portez
sur votre ancienne famille politique
et moi je me réjouis jamais de 2
l'état d'une famille politique qui
aujourd'hui vont nettement en
décrépitude
la question c'est comment en sommes nous
arrivés à ce naufrage là comment est ce
que les républicains ont pu atterrir à
8% la réponse est assez simple
au fond je le crois c'est que les
républicains ne savent plus où il habite
ils ne savent plus à quoi ils croient je
ne veux pas ciblé madame dalloz mais
pour beaucoup de députés ont voté
pendant ses deux premières années contre
des projets que eux mêmes avaient porté
pendant des années donc quand on ne sait
pas ce qu'on est là on perd les
élections et les républicains je voulais
dit tout à l'heure ce sont construit
uniquement dans une posture contre le
président de la république dans deux
lentilles mâcon primaire eh bien je
crois que ça a conduit leur naufrage
le monde a évolué et les anciennes
formations politiques n'ont pas su le
voir et n'ont pas su s'adapter
ce diagnostic que je porte sur le parti
des républicains je le porte aussi sur
le parti socialiste et qu'il faut que
ces formations politiques se réinvente
il faut qu'elle travaillait déjà sur
leurs politiques pour ses autres vouloir
madiambal il n'y a pas d'autres
formations politiques qui existeraient
mousserion ce que je déplorais nous
soyons dans un affrontement binaire
entre la réponse est un seul cas déjà
aujourd'hui le public n'en avons rien
créé je crois qu'on fait de la politique
et la conviction une autre je crois que
nous faisons de la politique pour porter
des projets si les républicains ont des
convictions qu'il puisse porter des
projets alternatifs est de même pour les
pour le parti socialiste les français
vous savez il se positionne par rapport
à des propositions ou à des solutions
qu'on leur apporte
c'est le cas des verts qui aujourd'hui
ont une percée parce qu'ils ont su
apporter des réponses à une
préoccupation majeure
je crois que ce match macron le pen peut
être très dangereux je le crois
dangereux quand je les dis je le crois
dans l'art de l'internât spacieux
démocratie et nous sommes en démocratie
la démocratie implique la circulation du
pouvoir la démocratie implique
l'alternance s'il n'y a qu'une
alternative à ce que nous portons ce
sera évidemment très dangereux parce que
un jour viendra et le plus tard possible
mais nous perdrons les agresseurs qui
manifestement prendre l'ampleur au sein
de l'ocs en tout cas c'est un discours
que je porte parce que c'est un discours
auquel je crois mais ce n'est pas à moi
de prendre la main des républicains à
prendre la main du parti socialiste en
leur expliquant que c'est à eux de ce2
ce2 se réinventer mais ils doivent se
réinventer
ils doivent pouvoir nous proposer des
solutions alternatives on ne peut pas se
résoudre
et je j'ai ce cri d' alerte on ne peut
pas se résoudre à cet affrontement la
seule alternative ne peut pas être le
front national le rassemblement national
parce que même avec des nouveaux visages
même avec des nouvelles pratiques
politiques ça reste l'extrême au raté
vous savez vous avez fait allusion tout
à l'heure à mon parcours auprès de
jacques chirac jacques chirac a toujours
construit des digues infranchissable
avec l'extrême droite parce qu'on ne
discute pas avec le front national on
rassemblement national on ne dialogue
pas avec l'extrême droite
on la combat et aujourd'hui je souhaite
la combattre et comment on combat
l'extrême droite on la combat en
apportant des solutions des solutions
très concrètes et des résultats en
matière de lutte contre le chômage
en matière de politique fiscale en
matière d'accès à des services publics
c'est en ayant des résultats et en
poursuivant notre travail de
transformation et de réformes et en
montrant aux français qu on est attentif
à leur situation et qu'on leur donne de
nouvelles clés pour faire face à leur
destin
c'est en apportant ses solutions là que
nous pourrons sortir de cette impasse où
la seule alternative possible serait un
rassemblement sur la très élevé
l'assemblée nationale qui a lancé sa
campagne pour les municipales hier vous
redoutez qu'il fallait ici ça contient
de nombreuses villes je ne le redoute
pas je le combattrai en tout cas et je
me réjouis par exemple que
cécile mu coty et étaient des ennemis
aujourd'hui tête de liste de république
hommage à toulon parce que je crois
justement que cécile mus coty incarne ce
qu'est la république qui n'ont s'incarne
dans les territoires libérés front
national et enfin le coup ça fait quand
même un petit moment qu'il est en
politique et que tous ces maires qui
vont vouloir aller à nouveau à la
conquête d'un nouveau mandat n'auront
pas forcément compris que la vie
politique a changé
et si hubert falco fait le mandat de
troubles je préfère en tout cas que
soient ses sinus coty qui porte un
projet progressiste dans la ville
qu'abandonner là vous mettez vous une
candidate la république en marche
il ya des endroits où il y aura des
alliances et notamment avec la droite
il ya peu de jours des mers 72 maires de
droite ont signé une tribune
et est-ce qu'il y aura des candidats la
république en marche pas c'est ça c'est
soixante douze maires qui ont lancé en
fait un appel à emmanuel macron une main
tendue je vous ai dit ma position par
rapport au maire je les lis par rapport
aux maires d'arrondissement mais ça vaut
pour tous les maires qui nous rejoignent
s'ils veulent nous soutenir ils sont les
bienvenus
mais il faut que moi j'ai pas de procès
d'intention ou de procès en un sincérité
affaires revanche je souhaite qu'il y
ait de la clarté dans ce soutien est que
la clarté se fasse sur la base de
position sont ils réellement
progressistes qu'est ce que vous aimez
porter un projet crettenand progrès
volts il adhéré à cette nouvelle façon
de faire la politique dans la nouvelle
façon de faire de la politique on
l'associé citoyens ont des bas mais
parlait tout à l'heure pour paris mais
on est aussi capable de passer la main
et de porter la logique de
renouvellement
je pense qu'avant obligation de signer
la charte d'engagement de l'arrivée
c'est comme la charte d'engagement je
vous parle de solutions et d'août n'ont
pas forcément la fratrie a par exemple
président du groupe applique en marche
au sénat dit qu'il est une obligation
pour ses marques de signer la charte
d'engagement fait savoir qu'ils
aimeraient mais si c'est ma position il
va de soi que ceux qui aimeraient être
avoir le soutien de la république en
marche doivent s'inscrire de manière
formelle dans le
le processus qui est établie mais ce qui
compte c'est que sur le fond et puis
savoir changer c'est moi je suis pas de
ceux qui vont critiquer le fait que des
républicains nous rejoignent ou que des
socialistes nous rejoignent c'est
précisément l'essence même de notre
vivant c'est le fait de pouvoir
s'affranchir de ses anciennes formations
politiques pour se dire tiens sur la
vision d'avenir qu'on peut porter la
vision d'avenir qu'on a on peut se
mettre en train prend pas très bien
votre stratégie en fait par exemple on
voit que le maire de reims arnaud
robinet à un candidat
la république en marche face à lui ça a
été annoncé aujourd'hui
en revanche on a l'impression que des
maires comme monsieur moudenc à toulouse
où d'autres maires christian estrosi ou
monsieur béchu par exemple sont
compatibles comment vous faites la
différence
et pourquoi est ce qu'il ya un candidat
chasse a expliqué que c'est ma stratégie
si ma stratégie était suivi pour
désigner candidat aux municipales pc
mais ça bouge dans la stratégie du
gouvernement que j'appartiens
précisément consiste à travailler avec
des municipalités sur des projets sur
des munitions des majorités des projets
de majorité municipale qu'est ce que
c'est que le progressisme municipal
j'ai dit ce que c'était là mon sens pour
paris sur l'environnemental sur l'enjeu
social sur l'enjeu sociétal
mais ces cétacés ta aujourd'hui
apparemment si le mouvement auquel
j'appartiens décidé d'investir quelqu'un
contre lui c'est qu'arnaud de robinet
n'allait pas présentés et notamment en
soutenant de manière assez officiel
françois davy bellamy aux européennes ne
présentait pas les garanties nécessaires
pour porter un projet progressiste
externaliser le progressiste et le
progressisme ça ne se décrète pas ça se
prouve le rassemblement ça se décrète
pas dans un bureau
ça se construit petit à petit et c'est
sur la base de ces preuves qu'on avance
ça vous partout en france
et ça vaut aussi à paris on va parler
des réformes à venir l'exécutif annonce
une nouvelle méthode plus de
concertation est ce que ces
concertations franc vers - qui loupe ce
que c'est juste un moyen pour vous de
gagner du temps non vous savez je crois
qu'on est sortis d'une période très
dense pour le pays avec la crise des
gilet jaune avec le grand débat national
le président de la république a fixé un
nouveau cap et d
l'idée de lancer un acte 2 pour ce
quinquennat lé premier ministre nous l'a
décliné la semaine dernière l'occasion
du discours de politique générale c'est
un nouveau souffle pour notre action
sans aucun doute un nouveau souffle
parce qu'il y à un changement de méthode
qui est annoncé on a très certainement
pendant les premiers mois de notre
mandat et je le dis avec d'autant plus
de facilité que je l'avais déjà dit à
l'époque mais que le sentiment d'urgence
nous imposer de faire des réformes
peut-être de manière trop vertical pas
assez concertée en associant pas assez
les corps intermédiaires les élus locaux
ou les français j'en fais vraiment
d'humilité mais je pense qu'il ya une
volonté d'aller vite d'aller loin et que
je dirais pas de manque d'humilité je
pense qu'on a pris les choses de
manières je résultat lui est même un an
ce brutal d'humanité voilà mais je crois
mais je crois profondément et je le dis
d'autant plus facilement je me dis que
j'ai moi même il ya quelques mois dit il
faut plus d'écologie plus de social et
plus d'humanisme dans ce que nous
faisons
eh bien je suis heureux aujourd'hui ce
soit un élément fondateur de l'acte ii
et l'acte ii c'est précisément une
feuille de route en matière écologique
une feuille de route en matière sociale
une feuille de route aussi dans la
transformation de l'état c'est la
réforme constitue l mais c'est aussi
l'acte de décentralisation je vous ai
parlé tout à l'heure de mon projet
parisien pour revenir sur le
millefeuille qui écarte les parisiens eh
bien nous avons le support législatif à
l'issue du grand débat il ya eu ce souci
de proximité et de quête du local parce
qu on comprend bien que les citoyens ont
envie de s'engager de participer de
décider eux mêmes de leur destin et
biens saisis sont nous de cet acte de
décentralisation qui viendra bientôt
dans le calendrier parlementaire pour
transformer l'architecturé
institutionnelle à paris ils
centralisaient si j'en crois que par le
niveau des arrondissements et là vous
nous parler de décentralisation parce
que c'est pas le trajet certainement du
mal m'exprimer je dis qu'il y ait un
double mouvement à voir les
arrondissements aujourd'hui ne servent
plus à rien c'est des mairies qui ne
sont pas des mairies de plein exercice
ya beaucoup d'élus et au fond ce n'est
pas la bonne échelle pour décider et les
arrondissements
créée en réalité du conflit de la
dilution des responsabilités et un
manque d'harmonie des politiques
publiques du nord au sud et de l'est à
l'ouest ce que je veux c'est qu'il y est
davantage d'uniformité et d'harmonie au
niveau d'une politique municipale
décidée par la mairie par ailleurs il
entre à la mairie de paris
fixe un cap la mairie de paris centrale
assume ses responsabilités
contractualiste avec des essais là parce
que c'est un double mouvement presque du
en même temps si je peux me permettre ou
confient à des conseils de quartiers
rénovés repenser au niveau du quartier
du pouvoir aux parisiens c'est au
parisien par les conseils de quartier
qu'il appartient de décider ce qui est
bon pour leur vie et on parlait tout à
l'heure des travaux tout à l'heure
précisément sur le sujet des travaux
c'est au quartier de savoir s'il y a des
travaux sur la prévision est un leurre
tous la blessure avoir exemple on dément
vous savez mais il y en a on a vu des
budgets participatifs dans certains hors
du jeu mais on sait bien récité devant
téléguidé par des investigations en toi
qui l'a fait raison je crois
profondément la démocratie locale je
crois profondément que l'élection
municipale même à paris c'est une
élection locale avec des préoccupations
locales et qu'il faut se départir de
tout enjeu national ou de toutes
considérations nationales il faut
apporter des réponses locales et dans
les réponses locales
je crois en la démocratie participative
je prends l'engagement
je crois dans ces valeurs qui justement
sont des valeurs nouvelles on doit
réinventer un modèle où le citoyen afin
que soient pipeauté à paris comme
ailleurs participent et décident ça veut
dire quoi
c'est à dire que je propose que sur les
budgets participatifs on double le
budget participatif qui est aujourd'hui
définie par la mairie d'arrondissement
par la mairie par pardon devant la
mairie centrale et qu'on puisse confier
ce budget de démocratie participative
doublé au quartier pour financer eux
mêmes des projets d'aménagement des
soutiens à des à des acteurs locaux
parce que je crois vraiment qu'il faut
rabaisser le centre de décision et le
centre de gravité décisionnel à paris
comme ailleurs au royaume
on va revenir méforme parmi les réformes
à venir la pma pour toutes qui serait
examiné en septembre au parlement
est ce que vous pensez qu'il ya un
risque de braquer les électeurs de
droite qui ont basculé ou qui pourrait
basculer vers nommé
le répète je ne fais pas de la politique
en voyant les conséquences que cela peut
avoir sur untel ou untel je fais de la
politique parce qu'on prend des
convictions
la pme va impacter la paix toutes les
femmes est un engagement de campagne que
nous avons pris en 2017 et évidemment je
me réjouis que ce soit inscrit au plus
vite au calendrier parlementaire
je suis très attaché à ce qu'on puisse
remplir cette promesse de campagne vous
y était favorable
je suis très favorable à l'encré n'est
pas un risque de divisions mais ce n'est
mais précision non pour sa part réveillé
la manif pour tous en mai précisément le
premier ministre a expliqué qu'il
fallait créer les conditions d'un débat
apaisé et il faut créer les conditions
d'un débat apaisé
il va y avoir des questions qui vont se
poser notamment sur la filiation
notamment sur l'accès aux origines mais
sur le principe le conseil d'état puis
le comité consultatif national d'éthique
puis la mission parlementaire sur la
bioéthique ont toutes été toutes ces
instances ont été consultés tout en leur
feu vert et jaune s'est opposé de
manière vive qui s'y opposera pour des
raisons qui lui appartiennent et je n'ai
pas à en juger simplement je considère
que quand on porte ces combats là encore
on n'a pas sa place bien sûr que non on
n'a pas exclu aura quitté le groupe
mais ça n'a pas sa place ça va deux fois
déjà reçu un nom mais je pense alors je
pense que quand on porte des propos
homophobes
quand on porte atteinte à l'engagement
et pas de propos y'a pas de promesses
progressistes dans ce que diagne estime
amnesty la droite pense et ce qu'elle
veut mais ce qu'elle pense là en
l'espèce elle n'a pas le droit de le
penser chez nous parce que nous ne
sommes pas une auberge espagnole où l'on
viendrait quel que soit notre
sensibilité ou nos idées tout se mette
sous la bannière de l'ares et puis quand
on croit en des choses je crois en des
choses et en l'espèce sur la promesse de
l'apn pour toutes
c'était dix dès la campagne électorale
et je m'étonne vraiment gagner style
peut-être d'autres je ne crois pas mais
puissent se découvrir des oppositions
certaines villes dans tout cas sur cet
excellent jeu voilà je pense que en tout
cas pour ma part il y aura un engagement
très ferme à le faire elle le faire vite
c'est une question d'égalité et de
dignité sur les retraites est ce que la
france de 2010 9 est prête à l'adie
danse de celle de 95 à mettre fin aux
régimes spéciaux c'est sur la question
des retraites là encore on a dit les
choses avant l'élection il se trouve que
le président de la république avait
annoncé une réforme des retraites
systémiques et non pas paramétrique
pardon de ce il s'agit donc pas de jouer
sur les paramètres mais de jouer sur le
système global du niveau de retraite
pour dire que 1 euro cotisé doit ouvrir
aux mêmes droits
quand on part à la retraite et bien
cette réforme nous la mènerons à son
terme c'est un engagement de campagne de
jean-paul delevoye fait un travail
formidable que je veux saluer de
consultation justement on parlait tout à
l'heure de l'ecoute de l'attention à
porter aux partenaires sociaux aux corps
intermédiaires
ce travail de maillage de construction
d'une situation d'une position
collective et partagée par l'essentiel
des acteurs et un travail qui est
remarquable je souhaite que évidemment
nous puissions tenir cette promesse de
campagne
rapidement mais qu'on puisse lui aussi
la risque est quand même là jeux
d'équilibré est ce qu'il faudra dire aux
français qu'il faudra travailler plus
longtemps pour toucher sa retraite foule
à taux plein il faut toujours être très
clair avec ce qu'on prouve est-ce que
vous l'êtes suffisamment genre sur sept
les airs avec ce qu'on propose aux
français la réforme des retraites a été
proposée de manière très claire au
président de la république et c'est
celle que je vous ai indiqué une réforme
systémique et parametric on est très
clair aussi sur le fait que l'âge légal
restera à 62 ans
les personnes qui voudront partir à la
retraite à 62 ans le pur on aimait très
clair au signal sur le fait qu' il y
aura des système de décote ou de surcote
pour qu'on puisse travailler plus
longtemps parce que c'est le sens des
grandes choses qui vous l'aura est ce
qu'il vous reste quelque chose de
du chiraquisme qui ne s'accommode pas du
maquereau nisme non je crois non mais
vous savez moi j'ai appris beaucoup
auprès de jacques chirac j'ai fait toute
ma toute ma vie et tout mon engagement
politique auprès de jacques chirac j'ai
appris surtout à aimer la france
j'ai appris à aimer les gens à aimer les
français et à faire toujours attention à
ce que notre pays soit rassemblée la
question de la cohésion nationale la
question de la cohésion sociale est une
exigence pour moi qu'il faudra tenir
dans les prochaines années parce qu'on
le voit la société est morcelé la
société est fragmenté et que l'unité du
pays l'unité des villes aussi l'unité à
paris c'est important on a vu récemment
que dans des moments de deuil de larmes
que ce soit après les attentats ou après
l'incendié notre notre dame
les parisiens arrivés à se réunir et
bien essayons de préserver justement ce
message d'unité et de rassemblement
autour de projets positifs on sait se
rassembler quand les choses ne va pas
bien
essayons de porter des projets positifs
qui font la nation française
qu'elle soit sur le renouvellement
peut-être des postes à l'assemblée
nationale vous êtes vice-président les
postes vont être remis en jeu est ce que
vous êtes candidat à votre réalisation
merci d'y prêter un grand honneur pour
moi
dix présidents de l'assemblée nationale
et une confiance de mes pairs confiance
du groupe de la république en marge mais
je crois aussi rapport amicales que
j'entretiens avec madame dalloz je suis
très heureux d'en être c'est une
question qui se posera le moment venu
mais le moment n'est pas encore venu le
moment venu après les bébés c'est quand
les échéances seront décidées par le
groupe
il ya un engagement mais il ya un débat
ou rouges sur les procédures il ya un
débat groupe sur les calendriers y aura
à faire de la cuisine interne pour voir
comment le règlement intérieur se
modifie et dans quel délai honnêtement
je suis pas complètement sûr que ça
passionne les français c'est pour moi en
tout cas d'être vice président de
l'assemblée nationale j'ai aussi
beaucoup appris sur la gestion
collective et sur l'autre mais oui les
uns et des autres dans cette réparation
vous êtes candidat bien
intéressant à l'achat gilles t'attendre
à sa réponse votre réponse
merci beaucoup d'avoir été avec nous
vers cyclisme a très vite la semaine
prochaine
[Musique]